(wailing in pain) "I'm sorry!"
So, in the very first sentence of the
New York Times' review of Reservoir Dogs,
Critic Vincent Canby wrote
"it's been an unusually good year for the discovery
of first rate, new American
film directors'',
Then goes on to list four films that
you've never seen by four directors
that you've never heard of,
none of whom lasted more than a decade
making movies, before continuing,
now add to that list the name of Quentin Tarantino.
I guess one out of five ain't bad.
(Screaming)
"You're gonna be okay!"
25 years after that review, Tarantino
is probably the most popular
living, working director in the world,
after maybe Spielberg and Scorsese.
His eight films have grossed over
$1.5 billion worldwide, and writing about
his work could fill a small library.
The quarter century milestone is a
good opportunity to look back at
how Tarantino's first film has aged.
I've a slight obsession with firsts,
with how things begin, and
the first shot of Reservoir Dogs is
probably the first that I think about
the most. Okay, yeah, obviously
I know this is not technically the
first shot of the movie, but
I've always sort of viewed the
diner scene that precedes the
opening credits as a kind of overture
of Tarantino's entire filmography.
Traditionally overtures are mood setters.
A little bit of music that sets the
tone for what's about to follow.
It's only natural that in Tarantinoland,
the overture is a seven-minute conversation
about Madonna songs and the merits of tipping.
''But no, society says 'don't tip these
guys over here, but tip these guys over here',
that's bullshit."
So, the first shot of the story
proper is this, and it's one of the most
electrifying openings in film history.
Like the first notes in the first
Led Zeppelin album.
Before you have a chance to blink,
you're involved. Your mind fans
forward and backward through time.
It's usual in film for actions to have consequences,
but here, consequences have actions;
actions you begin to imagine.
A heist gone wrong.
[Led Zeppelin's "Good Times Bad Times" playing in the background]
And just like you're in the past,
you're also in the future,
calculating how long this guy
has left to live and what can be
done to save him.
And of course,
like Mr. Orange bleeding out,
you can't escape the present either,
because that's what pain is;
a brutal and specific attention
to the present moment.
It's that pain, that panicked feeling
of time running out, that
separates this film from others
that begin in media res.
Whenever I create anything,
I always hold it up against the opening
of Reservoir Dogs; is the beginning as
attention capturing as this?
Does it have the same kinetic energy
launching you into the narrative?
It's here too, of course, that we're
introduced to the technique that made
Tarantino famous: the non-linear structure
of his story-telling.
In interviews, Tarantino compared the
Byzantine tracks of his early films
to novel-writing.
"Novels have always had just a
complete freedom to pretty much
tell their story any way they saw fit,
alright, and that's kinda what I'm-
That's kinda what I'm trying to do."
But while I think the comparison to
fiction is apt, I also think that there
is a relationship here again,
with music.
One of the things that I think helped
Reservoir Dogs age so well is
Tarantino's instinctive sense for
narrative momentum.
To me, the ordering of the movie
is a lot like an underexamined aspect of
popular music; the sequencing of albums.
One of the reasons I love Abbey Road,
for example, one of the reasons
I've listened to it so many times
all the way through, is because the
song sequence carries me through.
Even in the first half, where there's
no medley, the arrangement has thrust.
I mean, just imagine the change
in feeling if the album began with, say,
Maxwell's Silver Hammer.
[Beatle's "Maxwell's silver Hammer, playing in the background]
Now imagine the change in feeling if
Reservoir Dogs began here.
"Say hello to a motherfucker who's inside.
Cabot's doing a job and take a big
fat guess who he wants on the team?"
The sequencing in Reservoir Dogs
has the same natural rhythm as an
album cycle does;
offering a variety in tempo,
from intense, to reflective, and back,
while linking corresponding scenes together.
All Tarantino's films are constructed this way,
like albums; more like albums,
I think, than novels.
Even the ones with more
straightforward narratives.
[Rick Ross' "100 Black Coffins", playing in the background]
"And part of my thing when I'm
coming up with an idea
is to go through that record room
and go through those records,
and to kinda 'find the music'
or the 'personality' of a given movie.
It's like I'm looking for the rhythm
that this movie needs to play in,
I'm looking for the spirit and the rhythm
that this movie needs to play in."
The other thing that Tarantino is
most known for is his dialogue,
and of course, some of the references
in Reservoir Dogs haven't aged so well.
"You know who she looked like?
She looked like, uh, Christie Love.
Remember that TV Show?"
"Get Christie Looooove"
"Get Christie Looooove!"
"She's a cop?" "Oh yeah!"
"You're under arrest, sugar!"
(laughing)
Nobody today remembers the show
Get Christie Love,
but what's more important here is the concept;
people still talk about TV shows,
entertainment is still a common language
between strangers.
"Taking genre characters in genre situations
allright, and giving them a real life spin,
have them sound like real people,
like, y'know, me and my friends,
and just other people,
and make references that other people make..."
Reservoir Dogs translates into 2017
because the humanity and the comedy
that Tarantino breathed into genre films
is still felt all over Hollywood.
"Footloose;
and in it, a great hero
named Kevin Bacon
teaches an entire city full of people
with sticks up their butts that
dancing is the greatest thing there is."
I think the only context in which
Reservoir Dogs hasn't aged so well
is within Tarantino's own filmography.
For all the purchase it has on film culture
and popular culture, it's still very clearly
his most amateur movie.
It's impossible to say how it would
be received today if it was released,
because so much of cinema
in the past 25 years is influenced by
this style.
But I think Siskel and Ebert
got pretty close in their original reviews.
"I liked the movie as far as it went,
I wanted it to go further and try more."
"I had the same reaction, that it was
a lot of- an exercise in style, uhh
but then I got that really quick,
I mean, I understand what he's trying to do here,
which is to show things in crime movies
that crime movies don't show.
For example, the sloppiness, the humour...
But we get that within 15 minutes"
The missing piece to Reservoir Dogs
is the deeper character studies and exploration
of big ideas that you get in Pulp Fiction,
in Jackie Brown, Inglourious Basterds, and
Django Unchained.
However, I do think that there is one
point in Reservoir Dogs
where Tarantino does reach for something deeper.
The commode story sequence.
All of Tarantino's work comments on
the nature of storytelling itself,
but the part when Mr. Orange,
an undercover cop,
learns a fake story to sell the criminals
on his credibility,
is one of the best instances of this
in all his movies.
He splits the sequence into four parts:
Orange learning the scene,
Orange rehearsing the scene,
Orange performing the story for an audience,
and finally, the story coming alive.
It's an elegant illustration of how words
can transform into stories,
and stories into reality,
or into movies.
And it's a nice touch that the only thing
that keeps the cops from noticing the drugs
is a similar storytelling situation,
because stories can keep us from seeing reality too.
"Buddy, I'm gonna shoot you in the face
if you don't put your hands on the fucking dash!"
As an exercise in genre and style,
Reservoir Dogs is superb,
one of the best in film, and
if it falls just short of the transcendent
heights that Tarantino would later go on to reach,
that's not really a criticism because,
I mean, let's see you reach try to reach
''just short of transcendent"
with your first movie.
I think a good rule of thumb
for how well films have aged is
simply whether or not we keep
watching them.
25 years on, I'm still watching Reservoir Dogs,
and I'll bet that'll still be true
25 years and more from now.
Hey everybody,
Thank you so much for watching,
this episode was brought to you by VRV.
VRV is a service that pulls together
a lot of great content channels
like Rooster Teeth, Mondo,
Tested, Cartoon Hangover,
Crunchyroll and Funimation, it's cool to have those
two in the same place,
You can download the VRV app on
Xbox, Playstation, iOS, or Android,
and if you get the VRV combo pack
at this link, you can get a 7-day
free trial.
Once you get that combo pack,
I'd recommend that you watch a
show called March Comes Like A Lion
on Crunchyroll, it's a show about
A 17-year-old Shogi player
(Shogi is a Japanese foreign variation on chess)
Really good, it's beautiful, melancholy,
I think you'll really love it, also
Adam Savage's one day builds on Tested
is just a great time,
all the shows are in HD and ad-free,
I definitely recommend checking out the VRV app.
I'll see you guys next time.